CARTER MORGAN: This
week, we're talking
about Istio improvements,
Easy ML, and the real meaning
of cloud-native.
Welcome to This Week in
Cloud, where we serve
you the lowest latency news.
The Istio team's been hard
at work for the last year,
making Istio even better.
And version 1.2
is now available.
You can now set log levels for
the control and data planes
globally.
You'll also find tools to
validate your Kubernetes
installation against
Istio requirements,
plus annotations that eliminate
the need for time-consuming
declarations.
A bunch of previously
beta features
are now stable, too, so
grab that update today.
BigQuery ML already makes
it easy to deploy algorithms
with no prior Java or
Python experience needed.
And we just open-sourced
a bunch of SQL templates
for the most common
marketing-focused machine
learning use cases.
Whether that's customer
segmentation, customer lifetime
values, or conversion
and purchase prediction,
go borrow a template today.
More and more, adapting your
architecture to be cloud-native
is a modern business
requirement.
But that doesn't mean it's
always a straightforward one.
If you've ever had questions
about the costs and benefits
of going cloud-native, how
to chart a smart path to get
there, and, yes, even the
philosophical shift in thinking
about your application
that's often required,
take a deep breath.
We've got you covered
with a post that
outlines five
principles to master,
as well as plenty of resources
for further learning.
Get your head in the clouds.
If you have consistent uses
of CPUs, memory disk, or GPUs,
then you'll definitely be
interested in committed use
discounts.
These let you commit to buying
resources for one or three
years and give deep
discounts in return.
We've also launched
a new report to help
you see how you're
using your commitments
and where you may be
able to save even more.
Check out the blog for more
info, and start saving cash.
Thanks for watching.
I'm Carter Morgan.
And if you want to read more
about these announcements
or see a full list,
check out the link.
Have any thoughts or ideas?
Leave us a comment or Tweet us.
We'll see you in the cloud.